co-host of first things first every
single weekday from 6:30 to 9:30 a.m. on
fs1 Pro Football Hall of Famer Chris
Carter here on the Rich Eisen show how
are you Chris rich how are you doing
today buddy well I'll tell you what
everything looked good in the horseshoe
over the weekend that's for sure I
thought I was down in Florida for the
weekend but I thought I heard even the
Michigan people times I thought I
thought that they were just so happy
about Ryan day the Ryan day era starting
and they don't have a quarterback locked
into the NFL this is gonna be our year
and then about maybe four minutes into
the game they were doubled over like oh
my goodness
when's the next time we're gonna build
beat the Ohio State well I'll tell you
this Chris you didn't hear it from me
you didn't hear it from me in terms of I
had Ryan day on the show two weeks ago
and I know who is coordinating last year
in the big game and I also know you know
Haskins what he looked like when he came
off the bench when JT Parekh was hurt in
the big house a couple years ago I I'm I
am NOT asleep at this switch whatsoever
and actually without Urban you know
intimidating and looking and you looking
over your shoulder if you're Ryan days
cuz urban I mean he likes to play
conservative football good defense
special teams and don't take any chances
on offense now Ryan they can get this
job it's his team that University's back
and the fan base is so it should be
exciting I am worried about their
defense I think they're gonna have some
problems for the defensive line later on
especially their interior they've got a
couple injuries that I think that will
they'll hurt him as the season goes on
why and also urban was was was
entertaining and and and it was an
interesting mix on the set on Fox Sports
for college football do you think he's
done coaching Chris well unless
everything that his life I've known his
life for many years of everything that
Urban's told me from a medical
standpoint like all that stuff well we
just have to our miracle would have to
happen so for me it was completely
medical I'm very close to urban urban
code
me when I was over hi Oh state I looked
in his wife's eyes and I know she's done
and rich you've been this business a lot
you cover a lot of dynamic people like
people's on the field people in the mic
but when your spouse starts telling you
it's over with it's just a matter of
time you are not wrong Chris Carter you
are you are not wrong what a happy life
is there's no doubt about that
right here on the Rich Eisen show okay
what about let's let's dive into your
let's say I guess in a way with the
Buckeyes Zeke hearing he's on a plane
right now to Dallas are you hearing the
same thing Chris yeah I think Shannon
reported earlier that he had inside
information that Zeke was coming back as
a sign of good faith
but Jerry know during those can be a
special year
he knows big the special you know
football player but also as you know and
knowing Jerry man Jerry is a tough
negotiator don't let all them smiles and
all those subjects you know for you the
NFL if they were calling on one owner to
negotiate a deal they were called Jerry
Jones
so Zeke is the best running back in the
NFL and has proven it over three years
but because of off the field it's
allowed the water to be murky compared
to being a flam dunk to now he's got a
fourth Jerry and that's what he had to
do with this hole down yeah I mean that
hasn't been much discussed Chris cuz we
know he's led the league in rushing two
of the last three years and that the
Cowboys can talk about Tony Paula all
they want but it would be doing every
single team a favor if they can't get
Zeke on the field and they play that
team without Zeke but not much is
discussed about how the off the field
stuff has played into this negotiation
with the exception of Jerry alluding to
it when he said he had the right he's
earned the right to joke with Ezekiel
Elliott I'm wondering how much you think
that's been playing into these chats
well I know on Zeke side you know you
can your leverage is not coming and once
the season starts losing games but they
know the reality if Zeke had the same
reputation off the field is Todd Gurley
then there wouldn't have been any
problem
lady on bail suffered the same thing
Aaron Fitch first yeah [ __ ] purpose
tree concerned about the guaranteed
money but they were concerned just like
Ezekiel but in a different form or
fashion this guy might end up in the
principal's office he's already been
suspended once that being both of them
in L Bell and the Pittsburgh Steelers
they were very concerned moving forward
you know as far as wow you know do we
give this kid all this guaranteed money
and what could happen in the future so
it's a it's a reality man not only
should you pay your best players but
it's been a reality in the league for a
long time you pay your best citizen and
that's why I really had a problem with
Jon Gruden what he did with Khalil Mack
and Amari Cooper like these are great
guys you can start your start your
program around these types of guys but
he decided to do differ and actually
made an investment in Antonio and as you
can see him and and our Marya are
totally just two different people two
totally different characteristic crisp
that makes them
it sure does Chris Carter here on the
Rich Eisen show
do you like what Bill O'Brien and
Houston did over the weekend I mean all
in here
short and long term Chris or if I was
this was some time I tried to put myself
in other people's spot if my job was on
the line I wouldn't be caring about the
future you know it's everything called
me you didn't say Chris man I'm
concerned about your show and everything
man I'd open up my rolodex and pull out
every name that I know I would be I
would try to have I would spend all the
budget money for this year next year the
bills saved my career because we need to
find out deshaun Watson we know you
football can get knocked out in we saw
that in that division with Andrew Luck
that's all plain and simple if you don't
protect them they will get hurt and
their careers could be altered so why
don't you no I don't believe Council is
an elite player I believe they pay too
much for you no I believe he is above
average tackle he's not great in run
blocking so did they spend the ginormous
yes for an average player at this point
yes now
get better yes you can get better but
let's be real about it right now he's an
average NFL tackle and so clowny also
for cents on a dollar they sent him out
the door what do you think that means
for Seattle does that change anything
for you in the NFC picture him being put
there and the old NASCAR package that we
know that Pete Carroll likes to to
employ I mean Seattle did get better but
for me
clowny is a limited player like I can't
pay him that franchise tag over four
years I can do it maybe for one year but
I believe his injuries I believe they're
real and I believe the lack of
versatility Mikey
he's the stand up linebacker because he
has not dropped great it drop it in
space and look at the type of defenders
he's played with like he's only going to
have that type of fact in JJ Watt
getting double-teamed all the time but
what's gonna happen when you get TT so
for me the lack of overall productivity
yes is he a freak athlete yeah but
thanks to Michigan in the Citrus Bowl
spikes that's the best play that's
that's that's next-level trolling see
that's why you're in the Hall of Fame
Chris part of the reason why you're in
the hall now is well done
that was a great play yeah but can I
develop like it I mean he's a freak
freak athlete they caught Randy monster
freak but he developed the Davian clowny
has not developed so to me like what's
his versatility what can he do if he had
gained changer do you have to
double-team him to win the game and the
answer to that would be no so then the
last part of this it's so difficult to
accuse a team in the NFL of tanking
because there's no way that the Dolphins
who suit up on game day are gonna
purposefully lose there's no way Brian
Flores and his coaching staff are like
let's figure out a game plan where we
can actually look good but lose today
because we have to lose but when you
trade away players like this at the
outset of the season Kiko Alonso is now
on the Saints how can you not accuse the
Dolphins
tank for tool right here Chris man it's
ugly and rich you and I are fortunate
that we get to cover the MBA and other
sports right most guys are a Sikh
they're just only covering NFL so it's
totally foreign to them and the way we
talked about the MBA and ultimately the
product we consume their product we buy
their app MVA ticket we go to their gang
spend our money and when you don't see
the best players out there because
that's one thing that's one thing about
the Kaepernick thing that's always
disturbed me I've always been able to
say the National Football League it's
the best of the best it's the best
players in the world the MBA is the best
players in the world but when you start
giving away things and you start you
know that this team's not going to be
competitive
I mean Fitzpatrick like how much money
they paying him to take that beat
because I know if he signs there as a
free agent and they say you know
something we're not going to be real
good this year we're gonna get rid of
our left tackle the fitzy sign there you
know so for me the Dolphins they are
rebuilding I am glad to see Kenny
Steel's get out of Miami with everything
there with the owner and everything so
he can have a clear conscience to go
ahead and finish his career now I do
believe he could be the gym in this
matter
yeah DeSean he's got to be responsible
with the ball Bill O'Brien they got to
put together an offense that he doesn't
hold the ball as much but Kenny steals
man opposite of nuke man they could do
some damage in the NFL so I think the
DeSean is one of the most underrated
players we have in the league and I'd
love people talk about me more but man
did they pay a handsome price for an
average tackle and I believe an
underrated wide receiver Chris Carter
here on the Rich Eisen show you know
it's interesting you mentioned stills
going to Houston
I mean Dwane Brown would tell you the
Texans aren't the most woke team in the
league either Chris I mean what what do
you make of Flores seemingly sending
Kenny Stills out of town because of all
of this well if the original owner mr.
McNair was alive I probably have some
problems with but based on his stance on
you know the protests and everything but
he's not
and I believe he'll have an opportunity
to build do that types of things that he
deems to be important but Brian Flores
bike he works for a boss man we all got
balls and then we get orders a lot of
times man we don't like but what do we
do as far as keeping a job and being
professional you try to go about doing
that
and Brian Flores he's trying to build
his career is this the only opportunity
as African American that he might get as
a head coach I don't like the fact he's
going to take all these losses him and
Chris Greer
Chris Greer the general manager there
that's a rare combination as far as
African American in the head coaching
seat and in the general manager seat but
they are tanking we got to call it what
it is and it's going to be ugly and to
me I just
you put so many players safety at risk
so many guys can get hurt when I can't
depend on inferior line I can't declare
my left guard I can't I don't know the
center if he's qualified to get the
protection people get hurt and this is
man this is a big-boy sport man this is
not like basketball you can hide guys no
guys get hurt and that's what I'm
concerned about the whole image of the
league with the dolphins and what
they're doing yes they are tanking and
it's going to be ugly
well lastly on this subject do you think
it's possible knowing the league as well
as you do Chris Carter that the Dolphins
have seen enough out of Josh Rosen over
the last several weeks and practices
that they could safely say he's not
their guy despite coughing up a two and
I mean poor Josh Rosen I mean what a
situation to first-year head coach isn't
back-to-back years with defensive
pedigrees and now banged up offensive
line last year this one they trade away
their best left tackle and potentially
best wide receiver I mean how can you
possibly evaluate Josh Rosen through all
this unless they already have is that
possible Chris it's impossible for one
it doesn't match up with why do you
trade a two for him but rich you covered
this league enough and we don't talk
about it enough man there's things
called institutional talent that's
people picking the players people
understand the salary cap people
understand how to put a roster together
and
careers are determined off of that I say
1% of all the players only 22,000 of a
plate in the NFL they can be in any
system Tim Braun Barry Sanders these
dudes can Reggie White they can play
anywhere but the rest of us bro man we
need a system man Chris Carter need
three receivers I need to be in the
flock at six two and a half to 10 to be
able to dominate like we need a system
to build take advantage of our skillset
and josh has not had it and I believe
that his career will be altered that
he'll never be able to fix it because
you have to organizations give up one
you within the first two years it's hard
to recover from that and unfortunate for
him the team that drafted him and traded
for him were in the situation they were
in the time he came it's Kirk Cousins in
the right system with Kubiak up in
Minnesota Chris what do you think what
at the wait and see the thing about that
system is the system don't matter
because they paying him all that money
and when they pay you twenty eight
million guarantees and they've never
done that for any other quarterback man
this is results man Kirk Cousins got to
play big in the big games Dalvin cook
keep them healthy and then no more
excuses you can't do that kind of
scratch man you got to perform written
something you used to you know every day
they pay you all that bread and you get
it done not like Kirk Cousins see your
Michigan he's Michigan State all right
before I let you go Chris your Super
Bowl prediction it's gonna be on Fox in
in South Florida I'm sure you will be a
very large part of that coverage who
plays in that game best you can tell
here Tuesday after Labor Day Chris let's
go with my Philadelphia Eagles they
drafted me fly eagles fly a rematch
against New England Patriots knowing
that goes to four straight it's tough to
say it's tough to go in a different
direction from New England isn't it it
really really is and I'd like to pick
someone but I can't make a case for well
you know why you know why New England is
as good as
you're in you're out Chris right you
know that right well go ahead and kill
well I mean Belichick obviously has a
lot to say I mean Belichick is terrific
he is the modern-day Lombardi but his
extension on the field the man who gets
it done when it's all said and done the
man who is the goat the undisputed goat
at the position of quarterback Tom Brady
and the institution of higher learning
that did put him into the NFL is a large
part to do with that the University of
Michigan Chris oh yeah
Michigan is the only team to bill stop
Tom Brady actually from being productive
that's a great training ground the same
thing a Michael Jordan Chris I don't
want to hear it you know Mike was Jordan
Michael Jordan was going back to North
Carolina after you left Tom Brady just
started going back I wonder why you know
what Chris we're just gonna have to
grind it up you know I don't want to
take Nick Wright's role here in this
conversation okay you dick do a good
enough job I don't need to stomp on that
but we'll just agree to disagree on this
front that you are right that my man is
the goat you have the highest regard for
him yes yes yes Chris you take care of
yourself really appreciate you and the
phone call your show and and I hope to
do this more often appreciated man
right back at you that's Chris Carter at
Chris without an H Carter 80 on Twitter
at Chris Carter 1965 on Instagram and
you could check him out every single day
on fs1 for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app